(majestic music)
- I've never eaten at IKEA before,
but I've heard the food is fine.
- I've heard a lot about the meatballs.
I think they're gonna be great.
- The whole premise is
really disturbing to me.
That a place you can buy
organizational doors for silverware
and couches, you can also buy
meatballs and cauliflower.
- The value here is unbelievable.
To me that's the number one
most important thing about food
is cost versus case analysis.
Everyone's talking about how
cauliflower is the new potato.
- This is what Oliver had in his bowl when
he had to ask for more and I
told him no at the orphanage.
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
- I dig it. It's like comfort food.
- Yeah! I'm into it.
- Gruel, that's the word I
was looking for. It's gruel.
- It's not not gruel is what I would say.
- I think I would love to
like wake up every morning
with just a spoon of this
in my mouth to wake me up.
So the meatballs are like
the flagship IKEA vegetable.
- What is this? Is this barbecue?
- It's lingonberry sauce.
- Are lingonberries just cranberries?
- It's good, but I mean.
- If I was really hungry
and this was in front of me,
I would eat it.
- But I mean it's a good meatball.
- They're cheap. 5 bucks
for the whole thing.
- For $5 it's probably a great deal.
I'll say that. It's a great deal.
- I am glad that they
have veggie meatballs.
- It smells a little bit like stuffing.
IKEA has figured out
how to make Thanksgiving
into every dish they make.
- Bottoms up!
- Ding!
- They're pretty good.
- You know what makes it?
Is this butternut squash sauce around it.
- Is this the same stuff?
- I like, I like them. They're not bad.
- Veggie meatballs. They're good.
- The green beans, on the
other hand, not a big fan.
- Yeah, why is there so
much water in the beans?
(laughs)
- This is really beautiful.
- If there's one thing that
Scandinavians like it's their sweets.
- That's good. That's
some good lingonberry.
- Yeah! I think it is lingonberry too.
- Highly manufactured, but delicious.
- You know I can eat
several pieces of this.
- I mean we can finish the thing.
- I kind of want to finish this.
- Looks kind of like a cranberry.
- Yeah, but it's lingering on the vine.
- It tastes like Caprisun.
- You can't ever be angry
drinking out of a juice box.
- It's good.
- Katie likes it.
- It's good. It's like cranberry juice
but like a little more subtle.
- This would make a great
beverage. Like adult beverage.
- I can drink this all day every day.
- It's also organic, so.
- What? Shut the front door.
- Value is off the charts.
- The cake and the juice box like yes.
Everything else (shrugs).
- And the lingonberries, now a fan.
I now love lingonberries.
- This is the kind of food that
you buy like at Disneyworld
in a pre-packaged container
because you're in a rush
and like everybody is already cranky.
Like no one's happy.
But it's there, and it's food.
So everybody's gonna shut
up and they're gonna eat it.
They're gonna be fine with
it, and they're gonna move on.